moi
leur embarcation est sur le point de
couler quand on lit ce hors de l'eau in
extremis aujourd'hui ces migrants
seraient probablement mort noyé médecins
sans frontières et sos méditerranée ne
font plus de sauvetage avec l'aquarius
qui a rescapé trente mille migrants en
3e les ports européenne ne voulez pas
deux le bateau n'a plus de pavillon ça
ne devrait plus d'une semaine à tourner
en rond dans les eaux internationales où
personne voulait offrir son par personne
n'y a pas un pays sa planète
kita prête à vous prêter son pavillon on
a passé la loi partout puis les
personnes qui se donnent un pavillon sa
bouche à genoux choc
la président de médecins sans frontières
est en campagne pour faire reculer la
peur des occidentaux envers ces réfugiés
qui fuient les violences et les famines
s'échanger le récit sur les migrants
donc on les décrit plus comme des gens
qui vont nous envoyer on les décrit plus
comme un des potentiels personnes qui
vont devenir des terreaux et sont
décrits comme des gens qui vont venir
voler nos jobs ici on est décrit comme
des gens qui sont dans le besoin et qui
un jour vont contribuer à l'économie
d'un pays pour jouer en ligne ou fermer
les frontières n'arrête pas le flot de
réfugiés
on ne fait que les renvoyer aux pacers
criminels qui transforme des enfants des
femmes enceintes en esclave sexuelle
c'est qu'on retombe déjà dans des cycles
de passeurs de plus en plus brutaux
c'est un cycle infernal vers là-bas
parce qu'ils aient ce but si jeune et
beau petit peu plus puisque je les abuse
un peu plus peut-être qu'ils vont finir
par toi un peu plus d'argent
pourtant l'europe se targue d'avoir fait
baisser le nombre de migrants qui
atteignent ces rives en donnant des
milliards d'euros aux pays comme la
libye pour qu'ils les gardent en
détention le coup est humain des hommes
des femmes des enfants perdent leur vie
mais c'est sans frontières appuyé le
pacte de marrakech pour humaniser la
gestion de ce flot de 66 millions de
migrants qui ne cesse de croître malgré
les murs n'est pas parce qu'ils
traversent une frontière qui ont plus de
droits donc on les traite avec humanité
on l'est on et traite pas en les mettant
dans des centres de détention dans les
mettant dans des endroits qu'on appelle
des freezer aux états unis qui se met
qui font la cuillère pour se tenir au
chaud entre eux n'ont fait pas ça on ne
fait pas ça sinon ça fait des victimes
une petite boîte et my tech de 7 ans est
morte de déshydratation alors qu'elle
était détenue aux états unis après avoir
traversé la frontière avec son papa ici
sophie langlois radio canada montréal